[Music]
in a press conference with Vladimir
Putin Donald Trump refused to validate
the findings of a deeply corrupt and
compromised intelligence community that
has been working assiduously since
before he was even elected to discredit
and destroy him and the left behaved as
if the sky was falling Barack Obama's
CIA director John Brennan who calls
himself a non partisan American but who
voted for Communist Party candidate Gus
Hall for president in 1976 tweeted an
all-out hysterical mode Donald Trump's
press conference performance in Helsinki
rises to and exceeds the threshold of
high crimes and misdemeanors it was
nothing short of treasonous not only
were Trump's comments in basilic he is
wholly in the pocket of Putin Republican
Patriots where are you
representative Steve Cohen a Tennessee
Democrat outdid even Brennan in hysteria
tweeting a call for a military coup
where our our military folks the
commander-in-chief is in the hands of
our enemy Obama's Director of National
Intelligence James clapper who once
called the Muslim Brotherhood largely
secular said that the Trump Putin press
conference was truly unbelievable on the
world stage in front of the entire globe
the President of the United States
essentially capitulated and seems
intimidated by Vladimir Putin so it was
amazing and very very disturbing less
hysterically but in the same vein
twenty20 presidential hopeful senator
Kamala Harris a Democrat from California
tweeted this the whole world just
watched as the president sided with
Putin over u.s. intelligence agencies
there is no doubt that Putin has
launched attacks on the very heart of
our democracy and by not standing up to
him today
the president has invited him to do it
again in response to that david horowitz
offered a note of sanity saying US
intelligence agencies like the CIA
headed by John Brennan who voted for
Communist Party head during the height
of the Cold War and launched the Russia
coluche
which hunt and commis FBI Horowitz also
observed longtime appeasers of the
Soviet empire in the Democratic Party
want to restart the Cold War with a
Russia greatly diminished in power and
influence rather than see if we can make
deals with this thug regime to reduce
the dangers of nuclear war and rein in
Iran's terror regime longtime foes and
targets of the left should have seen
this but some didn't the hysteria was
not all on the Left Newt Gingrich
tweeted president Trump must clarify his
statements in Helsinki on our
intelligence system and Putin it is the
most serious mistake of his presidency
and must be corrected immediately
now what was Trump's treason what were
his high crimes and misdemeanors
the most serious mistake of his
presidency what was it exactly in the
words of NBC's Chuck Todd it was
essentially confessing to the world that
he believes Putin more than the United
States of America and its agencies but
this was not expected ly wildly
overstated and misleading President
Trump did not say that he trusted Putin
more than he trusted the United States
of America he expressed his skepticism
at the findings of intelligence agencies
that have been shown over the last year
and a half to have strayed far from
their mission and become deeply partisan
shockingly Corrupt Organizations bent on
finding enough dirt on him to remove him
from the Oval Office the president has
repeatedly referred to Robert Muller's
Russian collusion investigation as a
witch-hunt and that is exactly what it
is
on Tuesday Trump walked back some of his
remarks at the press conference saying I
accept our intelligence community's
conclusion that meddling took place from
Russia during the 2016 presidential
campaign but he added that the meddlers
could be other people also there's a lot
of people out there he also tweeted
Thank You Rand Paul saying who said the
president has gone through a year and a
half of totally partisan investigations
what's he supposed to think indeed just
as there are a lot of people who may
have meddled in the election there are a
lot of people in Washington such as
Muller James Comey and Peter Strock who
have been determinedly working to frame
in four months for collusion with Russia
for which they have been so far on
able to produce any evidence president
Trump was right to be skeptical of the
intelligence community and should stand
firm on that skepticism as well as call
for a thorough investigation and reform
of the FBI it is also interesting that
the people who are crying treason the
loudest today never uttered the word
when Barack Obama shipped billions of
dollars in cash in the dark of night to
the Islamic Republic of Iran even as the
mullahs were chanting death to America
treason is defined in American law as
giving aid and comfort to the enemy
wouldn't billions given to a terror
supporting rogue state be a great deal
more aid and comfort to an enemy than
some skepticism about our manifestly
corrupt intelligence agencies at a press
conference of course but the leftists
who were in hysterics over the Trump
Putin press conference are the same
leftists who applauded Obama's
generosity to the Islamic Republic and
fought desperately to preserve their
men's disastrous nuclear deal with that
outlaw state it's a classic case of
projection the ones crying loudest about
treason today are the ones who are
actually traitors I'm Robert Spencer as
Shulman fellow for the David Horowitz
Freedom Center and director of jihad
watch this video has been brought to you
by the Center for security policy
[Music]